nous sommes sortis en fanfare la fin de notre
film a lieu lors d'un festival de musique block party
au centre-ville de LA dans le but de le
tourner nous avons en fait organisé
un festival de musique block party au centre-ville de LA appelé
festival d'été
nous construisons un film
et nous avons invité tout le monde  pour venir gratuitement,
tout ce qu'ils ont à faire, c'est RSVP et ils
sont venus et nous nous sommes tous
amusés beaucoup de gens vraiment cool et funky
s'amusant avec des jeans bem Nicky Romero était
là Dirty South était là Ellie riots
était là Dillon Francis s'est présenté et a
animé  pendant un moment,
Zack est devenu ému au micro,
même vous les gars, vous avez fait votre part et rendu le
film génial, il y a beaucoup de
cœurs battants,
c'était vraiment magique et incroyable et
je ne pouvais pas demander une meilleure façon de
terminer cette expérience dans  ma vie
tu